this is where the full extent of Yemen's
hunger crisis is played out the aslan
clinic in the country's Northwest
helpless mothers bring babies desperate
for food hacia Mohammed is severely
malnourished on every bed lies a tiny
victim of the Civil War
[Music]
ten-year-old Asif has the body weight of
a two-year-old her skeletal frame
devastated by hunger and malnutrition
life for us is brutal especially here
while the United Nations can get limited
supplies in its called on warring site
to loosen their grip on key cities
before there was meat there was food
there was salad everything today
there is nothing now there's only hunger
this is why the flashpoint city of Hadi
de rebel-held but undergoing a massive
government offensive 70% of the
country's food import come through the
port peace talks underway in Sweden are
trying to ease the siege but a man
mediating between the site says a
breakthrough on her data and another key
battleground will be hard one if we are
able to achieve progress on those two
places and lift the threat of war to the
people in those two places I think with
a diner great service to the Yemen and
it will be a huge boost to when we get
back together again
early next year at stake is the fate of
millions of starving children and the
future of Yemen I'm now joined by get
couple era from UNICEF he's a recent
director and responsible for UNICEF's
operations in Yemen welcomes the
capillary we saw somebody distressing
images of children in Yemen you've just
returned from there tell us what you saw
there well Yemen has become hell on
earth for millions of Yemeni children
every ten minutes a child is dying from
preventable diseases those figures are
mind-boggling but the reality hits only
hardest when you are indeed in Yemen
when you engage with the children when
you engage with their fathers mothers
people who try to save lives
then only you realize how deep the
crisis is the warring sides in Yemen's
Civil War are currently holding peace
talks how optimistic are you that these
talks will work and how important are
these talks for your humanitarian work
on behalf of the millions of Yemeni
children we need to remain very hopeful
important however small steps have been
said last week in settling peacefully
the conflict in Yemen settling the
conflict is critical for the millions of
Yemeni children and not tomorrow it
needs to happen now now apart from
ending the conflict mr. capillary what
else can be done to help is the
desperate suffering in Yemen that you've
been seeing and talking about well first
in the absence of a peaceful settlement
organizations like UNICEF need no single
more obstacles to allow us delivering
this much-needed humanitarian assistance
too often all parties to the conflict
are creating unnecessary obstacles
preventing us from delivering the
assistance in time preventing us from
delivering the assistance at a scale
that is needed but also very important
that on top of the calm the end of the
conflict is for the international
community to reinvest massively in Yemen
unfortunately Yemen has been governed
for decades in a way that led to
deep under development unfortunately
Yemen has been governed with little
attention for the Yemeni people and
definitely not for the Yemeni children
so what we need in Yemen is unpoppable
of peace is a reinvesting in
reinvestment with at the center the
millions of Yemeni children get
capillary from UNICEF thank you very
much for talking to DW thank you